angela davis cup mit willkommen beim ein
video und zwar hab ich mich für heute
mal so dazu entschieden kommt sagst du
doch einfach mal den leuten die du auf
snapshot schickt mal irgendwelche snaps
irgendwelche verhaltens lustigen snaps
und so weiter haben auch ganz viele
gemacht des netzwerks so also ich denke
wie folgt mir da erscheint ein
das heißt folgen also ihr könnt mich
gern würde mich freuen ich brauchte
wirklich ziemlich viel und dann seid ihr
nächste mal inventur auch im video
einfach alex punkte verloren auf jeden
fall habe ich selbst willkommen da hab
ich überhaupt nicht mitgerechnet die
wahl zum teil richtig pervers ich will
gar nicht lang lang und wir fangen
direkt mal aber was ich sagen kann
bleibt auf jeden auf jeden jeden fall
bis zum ende dran
da gibt es auch eine ziemliche 40
verfehlte da gibt's auf jeden fall noch
ziemlich verlosung deswegen schaut euch
das video an und bis zum ende profil
spaß jetzt so dann gucken wir mal was
die liebe rosa diamant mir geschickt hat
sehr gute frage
das ding ist ich habe mich von advents
kalender bekommen
also ja ich hab halt kein ihr könnt mir
doch mal adventskalender schick oder
wenn du mir ein adventskalender schicken
willst dann schreibt nicht mal an dann
habe ich bestimmt ganz viele von euch
und dann kann ich jeden tag ein
adventskalender essen so mache ich das
egal wir machen weiter gucken uns mal
den snap von der lydia an sehr kreativ
ich habe jetzt nichts gegen kg b oder be
beautiful ist auf jeden fall ist jetzt
bezogen aber sehr kreativ wirklich
cooler snap können wir uns einfach mal
im bild dann von anna k
was jemals komisches
hilfe alter jüdischer abgesehen
ich habe jetzt gar nicht so schlimm was
da drauf stand ich guck mir jetzt kurz
diese mobile aufnahmen anderen kann ich
möchte das sagen was ist für leute gibt
einfach warum schickt man mir sowas
das ist doch was ist das für eine
krankheit ist dass irgendeine krankheit
so notgeile phobie oder so bestimmten
die hat auf ihre draufgeschrieben also
christian mein kumpel weiß nicht warum
auch immer
die lok lässt damit gemeinde ein euro 1
euro gleich sechs kann man machen kann
man auf jeden fall machen also christian
schlag gerät zu den euro schenk ich dir
sogar okay hier haben wir noch die mehr
für ich meinen fantreffen hat das wurde
schon vor ort gefragt ich hab doch schon
mal überlegt als jetzt in hamburg war
aber man hat natürlich auf der einen
seite davon dass ja nicht einfach so
klar wenn jetzt nur irgendwie so 100
leute kommen ist das glaube ich noch
aber ich kann sein ding ich 0
einschiessen ich kann es überhaupt nicht
einschätzen
wenn ich jetzt auf cnet von instagram
und youtube sagen würde fast daraus
werden würde keine ahnung ich kann es
nicht sein aber ihr könnt ihr einfach
mal eine stadt oder wurde es cool wer so
in die kommentare schreiben
er ist dass man durch und man kann ja
mal drüber nach dem eventuell menschen
der umgebung bin oder so also schreibt
meine stadt in die kommentare
okay nicht das snap von alina oder so
das geht vorüber aber das fällt mir
spontan ein dazu wir können sie einfach
mal so machen brauche alter wenn ich
meine haare blau
ich stelle mir vor ich müsste
weihnachten einfach so mit blauen haaren
verbringen manche videos von ihr haben
so viele likes aber keine ahnung die
sind dann wirklich so abgegangen wenn
dieses video 20.000 laischaft vor
weihnachten oder so ich weiß habe ich
mir das trauen würde happy ich will nur
ausgelacht werden mit blauen haaren aber
okay wir machen das wenn das ist schafft
und dann mache ich das auch mit video
beweist für mich in meiner hand kann ich
allerdings richtig studios hier fabian
fragen der hälfte bestimmt oder also bei
20.000 ich glaube das schaffen wir nicht
aber wenn dann mache ich es ohne scheiß
ich mache das aber nur so für eine woche
das das unter geht das überhaupt keine
ahnung was ich habe sich verstanden wenn
du grüßt aber richtig lust habt ihr das
gesehen
sie wird in franken hat ein dreh handy
oder so hoch geworfen weil diese hält
sich erschrocken hat sollte jetzt aber
stopp auf keinen bereich schalten und
zwar habe ich noch so eine verlockung
für euch ihr könnt mich etwas ganz
cooles gewinnt mir wohl von mutter stehe
das ist ein kissen shop da gibt es echt
lustige kisten wie zum beispiel dieses
playstation kissen oder so ein riesen
smiley da gibt es halt mega viele sachen
richtig coole design so und der hat mir
gesagt ihr pass auf du kannst davon ein
paar verlosen deswegen könnt ihr jetzt
einfach mal auf den shop gehen der link
ist in der video beschreibung und da
könnt ihr euch einfach ein kissen
heraussuchen was sie gerne arbeiten
schreibt mir einfach das kissen in die
kommentare und vielleicht noch eine
kleine begründung warum mir das haben
wollen würde mich freuen so einfachen
kommentar da lassen check das auf jeden
fall mal ja er sei an einer stelle würde
ich so was neben fisch auch voll war
dann ein paar von euch was gewinne ich
werde euch dann kontaktieren und und jan
sonst will ich sagen das waren mit dem
video das euch gefallen dass auf jeden
fall mal daumen nach oben oder halt wenn
ich mir die haare blau färben soll
ansonsten will ich sagen aber nicht
vergessen in seinem zettel war es ein
gewendet
nächsten mittwoch wieder hat